[Music]
it's been almost 17 years since the
first Kingdom Hearts released for the
PlayStation 2 while the series may go
down in in 3/4 its let's say difficult
to follow plot you can't deny the impact
its had on its legions of fans from its
beautiful music positive messaging about
the importance of friendship and the
marrying of two huge franchises Kingdom
Hearts has been a mainstay in millions
of people's lives for almost two decades
on the eve of the third game's launch
and the final part of Sora's journey we
thought we'd take a look at how Square
Enix and the House of mouse joined
forces to create such a beloved video
game series welcome to the history of
Kingdom Hearts
[Music]
to really understand how Kingdom Hearts
came about we need to go all the way
back to 1996 when a Nintendo released
their seminal 3d platformer Super Mario
64 the game had a huge impact on Final
Fantasy 7 character designer Tetsuya
Nomura who was struck by the sheer
amount of freedom it gave the player to
run around in its vast colorful 3d
spaces when Nomura told his colleagues
at squared that he'd love to make
something similar one day they told him
it would be impossible to make a game
like that from scratch because the only
way you could do it is with characters
that are as well-known as Disney's years
later
Final Fantasy creator Hironobu Sakaguchi
and Final Fantasy 8 producer Shinji
Hashimoto called Nomura into a room as
he arrived he overheard the tail end of
a conversation they'd been having they
were lamenting that Mickey Mouse would
have been a perfect character for an
upcoming project but Disney wouldn't let
them use him Nomura seeing this as an
ideal opportunity to execute his own
vision of an action RPG featuring
Disney's well-known roster of characters
raised his hand and told the - that he
would love to be on board with this
project they agreed to give him his
first shot at directing a title pieces
were starting to come together at square
but they still had to get Disney on
board at the time the two companies
shared a building and one day a chance
encounter between Shinji Hashimoto and a
Disney executive in an elevator gave
square the chance to put the idea to the
house of mouse quite literally an
elevator pitch while Disney were
intrigued by the premise of a game
starring their characters the initial
meeting didn't go exactly to plan Disney
were under the impression that Square
would make whatever Disney asked them -
featuring only the characters and
properties they wanted to be featured
Disney even started to pitch their own
ideas to square one of which being a
game where Donald Duck would star Nomura
cut them off mid pitch to tell Disney
that he wouldn't make such games
instead he told them about his early
idea for a 3d action game which featured
new characters adventuring through
Disney worlds he accompanied this pitch
with concept art of the game's main
character Sora this Sora wielded a huge
chainsaw blade over one shoulder and
rocked a pair of lion ears and a big
fluffy tail
according to Nomura this character
revealed was met with astonished silence
from Disney which led to him making a
few adjustments the chainsaw blade was
redesigned to become the iconic Keyblade
Sora's lion aesthetic was deemed to be a
little too similar to Final Fantasy 9
sedan
so the ears and tail were also dropped
in a later redesign his white gloves red
shorts and yellow shoes were a clear nod
to Mickey Mouse as usual apparel Disney
eventually accepted this Sora as the
main character for the project but as a
show of good faith Square also offered
to use some of its more recognizable
Final Fantasy faces like Leon and cloud
as supporting characters when it came to
selecting Disney's characters the
development team were able to meet with
then-president Bob Iger who was very
generous in letting square used Disney's
vast roster of properties as well as
working with the development studio to
give them access to allow Square to
replicate the characters and worlds when
naming the game Nomura wanted something
that fit Disney when he thought of the
game he thought of Disneyland and the
attraction that stuck out to him was
animal kingdom he wanted to call the
game Kingdom but he couldn't get the IP
for that as a title heart was a core
part of the game story so it was added
throughout development Square originally
was concentrating much more on the
gameplay wanting to make something that
would appeal to Disney's generally
younger audience
however Nomura received something of a
talking-to from Hironobu Sakaguchi who
told him that if his game didn't strive
for the same level of storytelling as
Final Fantasy then it would be a failure
so we have the father of Final Fantasy
to thank for all of this
so fellas did somebody mention the door
to darkness
[Music]
[Music]
now this video isn't going to go into
the real nitty-gritty of the Kingdom
Hearts story because well we'd be here
all week but in a nutshell Sora's
homeland destiny Islands is attacked by
an enemy called the heartless they're
created when a person's heart is utterly
consumed by darkness and they have a
driving need to seek and consume more
hearts even those of worlds amidst the
chaos
Saurus two friends Riku and Kairi vanish
and Sora is transported to a new world
there he crosses paths with Donald Duck
and Goofy both members of King Mickey's
Court who are on the hunt for their
missing leash whose parting words told
them to find a key interesting side note
that despite being a driving force for
the narrative Mickey is actually
surprisingly absent from Kingdom Hearts
making only a brief cameo towards its
end anyway
Becky is Sora's Keyblade a weapon with
the ability to close the keyholes two
worlds thus protecting the heart of the
world from being consumed by darkness
various Disney fillings led by Sleeping
Beauty's Maleficent are on the hunt for
the seven princesses of heart who can
summon the keyhole to Kingdom Hearts the
heart of all worlds and a source of
power and wisdom the Disney villains
even recruit Sora's friend Riku into
their ranks
duping him into promising to help him
find Kyrie also vying for the path to
Kingdom Hearts is Keyblade masters a
nought effectively the villain of the
series who appears throughout the games
in various guises but trust me this is
not a rabbit hole you want to fall down
considering the development team working
on Kingdom Hearts it's no surprise that
the series shares a lot with Final
Fantasy including characters items and
elements of its gameplay like casting
magic and calling in
[Music]
it's biggest departure is that Kingdom
Hearts plays much more like a
hack-and-slash in fact a lot of the team
had never worked on an action game of
Kingdom Hearts is ilk and Namur himself
said there were some really dark moments
during development in the game you play
as Sora without his lion tail backed up
by an AI controlled Donald and Goofy but
in certain worlds you can swap them out
for someone more local like say Aladdin
in Agrabah it features an experience
points based levelling system and
players could customize how they leveled
by choosing from various options at the
beginning of the game Sora and company
can travel to a number of Disney worlds
including deep jungle from Tarzan
Halloweentown Olympus Coliseum and the
Hundred Acre Wood there were also some
original worlds like Sora's home world
of Destiny Islands and Travis town to
travel between them you can build and
board the gummi ship and fly along the
route to each world attacking heartless
as you go as well as having access to
Disney worlds and characters Kingdom
Hearts used a lot of the original Disney
voice actors Kathryn Beaumont who voiced
Alice from Alice in Wonderland in the
1951 movie reprised her role for the
2002 game other famous names in Kingdom
Hearts include hero stop hayden
Panettiere as Kyrie Haley Joel Osment as
Sora veteran actors like Leonard Nimoy
and Christopher Lee would appear in
later games and for some reason Lance
Bass from NSYNC played Sephiroth
[Music]
the main theme hikari or simple and
queen was performed by Japanese singer
Hikaru Utada when asked why he chose you
tada for the theme Nomura replied I
thought that since we were using
world-famous Disney characters
we'd need a song by the very best
artists for me that could only be you
tada-san the music in kingdom hearts was
composed by Yoko Shimomura who had
previously worked on Super Mario RPG and
Street Fighter 2 and would go on to
score Final Fantasy 15 she's called her
work on Kingdom Hearts the most special
to her and it's easy to see why
[Music]
Kingdom Hearts released in 2002 to
positive reviews GameSpot gave it an 8
point 2 out of 10 praising the huge boss
battles and the way the game
successfully married the spirit of
square and Disney together but
criticized the wonky camera controls and
the sometimes unsatisfying exploration
according to square the game sold almost
5 million units making it one of the
best-selling PlayStation 2 games of all
time
shortly after its release a Kingdom
Hearts television show for the Disney
Channel was in the works
Seth Keys Lee who had worked on shows
like Timon and Pumba The Simpsons and
Dilbert was due to develop and direct an
animated series based on Sora's
adventures it was set to combine the
anime aesthetic of the Kingdom Hearts
and Final Fantasy characters with the
look and feel of a classic Disney
animation
despite the pilot animatic testing well
the show was shelved and never saw the
light of day beyond these storyboards
but a manga based on the events of the
game did end up being released less than
a year after the game launched square
released Kingdom Hearts final mix in
Japan which featured a new difficulty
level gameplay tweaks new weapons
enemies and cutscenes we didn't actually
see it here in the West until it was
released as part of Kingdom Hearts HD
1.5 remix for PlayStation 3 over 10
years later for the HD remake it wasn't
as simple as simply porting the game to
a new console because the game data for
the original had been lost and so most
of the graphics had to be completely
remade and the music re-recorded
in 2004 chain of Memories launched for
the Game Boy Advance it served as a
direct sequel to Kingdom Hearts and a
prequel to Kingdom Hearts 2 according to
Nomura chain of Memories was created for
the Game Boy Advance because he'd heard
a story that kids in Japan wanted to be
able to play Kingdom Hearts on a
handheld console and figured that there
would be similar demand overseas but the
Game Boy Advance wasn't powerful enough
to create a 3d action game like the
original so chain of Memories became a
2d game that featured an entirely new
card based battle system in fact Nomura
had already been toying around with some
ideas for a card game and chain of
memories was his opportunity to try it
out it was also one of the first Game
Boy Advance games to use FMV cutscenes
[Music]
chain of Memories followed Sora Donald
goofy and Jiminy Cricket as they
searched for Riku and King Mickey in
castle oblivion the stronghold of a
mysterious group known as organization
xiii now organization xiii are made up
of nobodies we'll get on to that later
who are looking to reclaim their hearts
upon entering the castle all of the
heroes fighting and magical abilities
are lost but they're able to visit
worlds and levels using cards made up
from Sora's memories Sora discovers that
a girl named nómine was being coerced
into manipulating his memories by a
rogue member of organization 13 Sora
agrees to go into a deep sleep so that
nominee can rebuild his old memories
upon completing the game
there was a second storyline where you
can play a Sora's friend Riku as he
battles through the castles dungeons
chain of Memories was critically
well-received and the game eventually
went on to sell over a million and a
half units it was remade for the ps2 in
2007 in Japan and was bundled with
copies of kingdom hearts 2 final mix
eventually being released as a
standalone game in North America in 2008
in 2004 a spin-off Kingdom Hearts mobile
game was released for Verizon's V CAST a
subscription service that allowed for
access to and rapid downloads of videos
mp3s and games over a 3G connection
Kingdom Hearts V CAST is considered to
be non-canon because it wasn't made by
Square Enix and has no ties to the
events of the main series but it
features some familiar characters such
as Maleficent and Jafar it also added
new characters like swordsman parrot who
has never appeared in another Kingdom
Hearts game since widely considered to
be lost to the ages in 2016 wedge a
member of the 4chan Kingdom Hearts
community discovered the very first
chapter of the game on an old mobile
phone and uploaded it to the web
[Music]
[Music]
in late 2005 in Japan and in 2006 for
the rest of the world the eagerly
anticipated Kingdom Hearts 2 released
for the PlayStation 2
[Music]
[Music]
instead of playing a surah who at this
point in the story was in a deep sleep
as nomine rebuilt his memories we began
the game as Roxas an ordinary kid on
summer break who just wants to hang out
with his friends but it turns out that
Roxas is actually Sora's nobody now a
nobody is formed when a strong-willed
individual loses their heart
Roxas was formed at the end of Kingdom
Hearts when Sora gave up his heart to
save Kyrie after a couple of hours
playing as Roxas he finds Sora and the
two characters merge and Sora manages to
become whole again you're lucky
looks like my summer vacations
over
roxas was the thirteenth member of
organization 13 the group of powerful
nobodies who we met in chain of Memories
who are on the hunt to gather hearts to
form a new Kingdom Hearts which they
believe will give them the knowledge to
understand the heart then they can
reclaim their own hearts and become
whole again your art is all you have a
conscience when was the last time any
one of us felt anything truer words were
never spoken well I suppose the fun will
have to wait Sora Donald and Goofy
Traverse Disney worlds tackling the
organization and the Disney villains
once again as well as the leagues of
nobodies and heartless as they hunt for
Riku and Kairi
[Music]
square-enix began preliminary work on
Kingdom Hearts 2 after they shipped
Kingdom Hearts final mix but development
slowed while they awaited sign-off from
Disney for one key aspect of the game
which was making sure that Mickey Mouse
got a bunch more screen time once they
got the go-ahead development went full
steam ahead Garrick is like Steamboat
Willie there Mickey Mouse gameplay was
tweaked and refined with all of Sora's
combat animations being remade for the
new game Nomura explained that they did
this because Sora would have matured in
that time and they wanted his new move
set to look a little cooler and not like
a little kid learning how to use a toy
the biggest new additions to gameplay
were Sora's dry form that allows him to
merge with his allies and have extra
powers and reaction commands that give
contact specific abilities and actions
square also improved the camera controls
which many players had problems with in
the first game the gummi ship was
tweaked
according to Nomura to give a little bit
more story making it feel more like a
Disney park ride that has some purpose
rather than just simply being a way to
get from A to B in Kingdom Hearts 2 we
travel to bold new worlds including
Pirates of the Caribbean the lion Kings
pride lands and space paranoids from
Tron many familiar worlds also return
including Halloween town and the Hundred
Acre Wood Atlanticare definitely had
some big changes what a song Kingdom
Hearts 2 received highly positive
reviews with critics praising the cameos
from Disney characters and improvements
to gameplay in particular the fix to the
camera it tied with Resident Evil 4 as
firm it Sue's Game of the Year and was
the second best-selling game on any
console in 2006 by the end of 2007 it
had shipped over 4 million copies
kingdom hearts 2 final mix was released
in Japan in 2007 once again it came with
new cutscenes gameplay tweaks including
a new drive form and a harder difficulty
mode with such critical and commercial
success everyone's eyes were on Square
Enix to hurry up and release the sequel
but it wasn't going to be quite that
straightforward Nomura had some
experimenting to do on handheld consoles
first
[Music]
whoa what now
[Music]
that voice who's there Mickey
Wow
Kingdom Hearts coded is an episodic
mobile spin-off that was released
between 2008 and 2010 taking place just
after the events of Kingdom Hearts 2 it
follows the gang as they try to uncover
the meaning of a mysterious note left in
jiminy crickets journal King Mickey
digitizes the journal to try to uncover
more but there are bugs in the finished
product King Mickey creates a digital
surah to fix the bugs and get to the
bottom of the mystery codes gameplay
features a mix of platforming puzzle
solving and the hack and slash combat
from previous games in the series
originally it was a Japanese only
release but it was remade for the
Nintendo DS and made available in North
America and Europe for the first time in
2011 under the name Kingdom Hearts
re:coded
this new version featured changes to
gameplay leveling and new cutscenes upon
release it was praised for its graphics
and the variation in its gameplay but
criticized for its tepid narrative it
was also added to the 2.5 remix
collection as a three hour long
cinematic square couldn't add the game
in a playable format to the collection
as it would require a full remake but
instead added almost two hours of new
cutscenes in order to give the viewer
the whole story I have the Keyblade
again I'm gonna help you find a way back
[Music]
maybe just a little another for a for
the series on mobile was Kingdom Hearts
mobile which launched in 2008 it was a
social network for Kingdom Hearts fans
where they could play minigames download
wallpapers and dress up their avatars
inside a location called the Avatar
Kingdom
whenever players completed an episode of
Kingdom Hearts coded they would unlock
new items in Mobile if the adorable art
style looks familiar it's because the
artist and designer monsta octopus
worked on kingdom hearts mobile as well
as Theatrhythm Final Fantasy Kingdom
Hearts mobile never released outside of
Japan and was shut down in 2013 today
makes 255 what's that about it's been
that many days since I first joined the
organization man time flies so you got
the number of memorized do you set
between 1 and 2 and running a long side
chain of Memories Kingdom Hearts 3 5 8
over 2 days has you play as Roxas once
again in this game you follow him as he
joins organization 13 and starts to go
on various missions with its members
including number 14 XI on a replica of
Roxas created from Sora's memories
although it was released on the Nintendo
DS 3 5 8 over 2 doesn't really make any
use of the system's touchscreen in fact
you can complete the whole thing without
using the stylus at all for the first
time in the series it featured a
multiplayer mode and you could use the
touchscreen to chat with fellow players
up to 4 could play together each is one
of the members of organization 13
meaning that everyone would play with
different weapons and abilities you
could also choose to do these missions
solo with AI companions a match-three
flash game called Kingdom Hearts magical
puzzle clash was released onto the
Disney website to promote the game three
five eight over two days sold over 1.2
million units and was the 12th
best-selling game in Japan that year it
was considered for a full remake like
chain of Memories to put it on home
consoles but instead was turned into a
long cinematic like coded
it was included in Kingdom Hearts HD 1.5
remix in 2010 birth by Sleep was
released for the PlayStation Portable it
had three different scenarios to play
through each following a different
keyblade wielder Terra Ventus and aqua
as they battle against day or not they
not believes that the light and the
darkness are unbalanced so he aims to
reforge the original keyblade and use ik
to ignite a new Keyblade war that will
hopefully bring balance to all things
however by the time he realizes this
true purpose in life he's grown old and
so begins to transfer his heart and
knowledge into the bodies of others
which is why he appears throughout the
series in many different forms he also
sends different incarnations of himself
back through time to help fulfill his
plan look just don't think about it too
hard despite being a prequel title birth
by Sleep offers a ton of plot
development and more clearly explains
the motivations of the series main
antagonists both by sleep experimented
greatly with its gameplay offering new
abilities and new mechanics such as the
command board and d-link which let you
take on the powers of another character
for a limited time it also featured a
multiplayer mode
both by sleep received mainly positive
reviews and ended up selling over a
million units
GameSpot's Kevin Van Ord praised the
switch up of the combat and of course
the over-the-top boss fights but
criticized the repetitive nature of the
game Kingdom Hearts 3d dream Drop
Distance released for the 3ds in 2012
master yen sid commands that sora and
riku take their mark of mastery exam in
order to become Keyblade masters in
anticipation of Seiya naughts return
Botha tasked with entering the world of
sleep in order to awaken 7 world's
Nomura said that he liked to experiment
with gameplay in the handheld Kingdom
Hearts games and nowhere is that more
apparent than in dream Drop Distance by
combining dream fragments players could
create spirits which acted as allies in
battle and the game featured a new
mechanic called the drop gauge which
depleted over time once empty you would
swap to the other character motion was
also radically different players would
drop into each level through a dive
section and thanks to a new system
called flow motion characters had much
more mobility they were able to grind on
Rails and bounce off walls it also
featured a multiplayer mode
unlike three five eight over to dream
Drop Distance actually used the 3d s
touchscreen functionality as much as
possible including touchscreen minigames
and AR cards to unlock dream eaters for
the game the development studio at
Square Enix responsible for dream Drop
Distance contains staff members who had
recently worked on The World Ends With
You and so instead of Final Fantasy
characters they used characters from
that game they also used new worlds from
movies such as Fantasia and The
Hunchback of Notre Dame after many
requests from fans dream Drop Distance
received mostly favorable reviews and
was widely praised for the variety of
its gameplay
especially the addition of flow motion
but it was criticized once again for its
impenetrable plot you can see that this
is a recurring theme with Kingdom Hearts
games
[Music]
Kingdom Hearts key was a free-to-play
browser game released in 2013 it was set
over a hundred years before the events
of Kingdom Hearts in the run-up to the
Keyblade war the player can customize
their own avatar and choose one of five
factions to join each run by a different
Keyblade master known as a foreteller
who's trying to prevent the world's
destruction as foretold by an ancient
prophecy they're doing this by vying for
control of the light in the world key
had a cute art style reminiscent of
Kingdom Hearts mobile and as players
would be using a mouse instead of a
controller its combat was mostly card
based the pc version of the game was
shuttered in 2016 but a version was
released on mobile as Kingdom Hearts
Unchained key in 2015 in Japan with a
worldwide release the following year the
mobile game was later rebranded as
Kingdom Hearts Union cross a 60 minute
movie called Kingdom Hearts key back
cover was released as a part of Kingdom
Hearts HD 2.5 prologue and helped
explain the actions of the foretellers
in 2017 Square Enix released Kingdom
Hearts HD 2.5 - prologue a collection
made up of dream Drop Distance HD
Kingdom Hearts key back cover and no
point to birth by Sleep a fragmentary
passage yes that's it actual name let's
move on a fragmentary passage acts as an
epilogue to birth by Sleep as well as a
taster for Kingdom Hearts 3 and
preparing for the final showdown against
Z naught master yen sid gathers Riku
Kairi and King Mickey and his tower and
tasks them with finding the three
Keyblade wielders aqua Ventus and Terra
Mickey reveals that he last saw aqua in
the realm of darkness a fragmentary
passage follows her journey through
there her meeting with King Mickey and
her sacrifice to save Riku a fragmentary
passage has a relatively short
three-hour running time but it has a ton
of collectables for you to run around
and find the gameplay is more in line
with what we can expect from Kingdom
Hearts 3 in a fragmentary passage we're
playing his aqua once again but we don't
have the command deck from birth by
Sleep and aqua spells are more similar
to Sora's it was also made on Unreal
Engine 4 as a taster of what 3 would
look like in game spots review we called
it the best Kingdom Hearts has ever
[Music]
at Sony's pre Tokyo Game Show event in
September 2018 Square Enix revealed the
Kingdom Hearts VR experience for
PlayStation VR a 10-minute interactive
music video featuring key scenes and
music from the series it was due to
launch on December 25th of that year but
was pushed to January 2019 at the last
minute with a follow-up episode jus in
spring
[Music]
and now almost 17 years since the launch
at the first game Kingdom Hearts 3 is
finally upon us it was unveiled Sony's
e3 press conference in 2013 and will be
the first in the franchise to appear on
xbox however after the event Nomura
himself said that he believed the game
had been revealed far too early
development had only just begun on the
game using Square annexes internal
luminous engine in 2014 and decision was
made by higher-ups at Square to switch
to epics Unreal Engine 4 meaning that
Nomura and the team had to redo about a
year's worth of work picking up after
the end of dream Drop Distance Kingdom
Hearts 3 we'll see the final showdown
between Sora and Zeya notes as the
former attempts to stop the latter from
balancing the light and the darkness
Mickey and Riku are on the search for
previous Keyblade wielders Aqua Terra
and Ventus
while Sora Donald and Goofy are on the
hunt for seven guardians of light and
the key to return hearts they'll travel
across a number of returning disney
world such as the Hundred Acre Wood the
Caribbean and Mount Olympus as well as
new ones from more recent movies like
San fransokyo and frozen's arendelle
over the past 15 years Disney has made a
number of acquisitions that could add
even more worlds to Kingdom Hearts while
Star Wars and Marvel heroes weren't
available for Kingdom Hearts 3 because
they were under a different company
within Disney Square were able to use
Pixar characters and worlds and it's
just as well because speaking to edge
magazine Nomura revealed that he
wouldn't have made Kingdom Hearts 3 if
he wasn't able to use Pixar the first of
the Pixar worlds to be revealed was toy
box a toy story world revealed at d23 in
2017 but this actually wouldn't be the
first time that Woody and Buzz have
appeared in a Kingdom Hearts game models
for both characters were found in the
code for 2007 kingdom hearts 2 final mix
presumably to be added to the game as
bonus content to celebrate Disney's
recent purchase of Pixar
[Music]
[Music]
gameplay in Kingdom Hearts 3 has
undergone a few changes the party size
has increased from 3 to 5 meaning that
Sora Donald and Goofy can have a couple
of extra guests from each world they
visit during the fight there's still the
usual hack and slash combat as well as
magic and character summons which are
now called links but Sora can now also
summon Disney park rides to aid him in
battle
the iconic weapon the Keyblade can now
transform into different variations to
offer new gameplay options movement in
three has been based on dream Drop
Distance 'as flowmotion
meaning that Sora can now propel himself
around using the environment making
traversal much more important than ever
before over a month before the game was
due to launch some Xbox one copies
leaked and were being sold online Nomura
responded on Twitter to plead with the
community not to share any of the leaked
information and assured fans at the
game's epilogue and a secret movie said
to be the biggest spoilers in the game
would be released via patch post launch
so that everyone can enjoy them all
together
[Music]
Kingdom Hearts means so much to so many
people after all many of its fans have
quite literally grown up with the games
and with Sora as a character myself
included it's very surreal to me that
after so long we're finally going to be
able to play the final part of his
journey he is hoping the weight was
worth every minute thank you so much for
watching this episode of history of and
a very special thank you to KH
insider.com
which has been an incredible source of
information now I touched on the story a
bit I didn't go into too much detail but
if you want a full recap on the events
of Kingdom Hearts then make sure to
check out Steve's piece on games become
will link it in the description below
thanks again for watching and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you